i think all businesses you know
especially food and beverage uh
we're facing new challenges you know but
we got to quickly adapt we wanted to be
involved with the community
for them to get to know us and we get to
know them you know what better spot than
downtown
we also have tourists celebrating
independence day you know after you know
the whole shutdown and the pandemic
everything uh you know uh
hopefully getting back to normal you
know we're headed in the right direction
uh
being able to celebrate you know being
able to bump you know elbows with uh
other people and celebrating and you
know just
our independence right off the back
since we make our own tortillas from
scratch
uh we came up with you know sourcing
some uh some red heirloom
corn white uh blue and and celebrate
that way man
so we're gonna make our tacos on red
white and blue tortillas i got about you
know 40 pounds worth of masa ready to go
and we're going to be selling them until
they sell out no extra charge is just
you know
a way to celebrate man